foreign
next question I just had a baby and I'm
concerned about the rise of RSV my
family gets mad when I won't let them
hold her what can I do to keep her safe
your family doesn't get a vote they
don't get a vote and
first time baby uh
um
was I'll just say anxiety even though
it's that's not clinically accurate just
the anxiousness you get about
cleanliness am I doing this right is
this the right diaper or is
microplastic's gonna get in my baby and
it's the pollution going to do this and
what about it that's completely normal
and so what I know about me is when I
get
um worked up about something I get
really emotional about something when I
get emotional about something
neurologically I don't make good choices
and so one of my life's goals
is to have a person
just today just today I called a friend
who's a banker who I love and I trust
and I said I'm having a challenge with a
financial decision I'm going to make
and you are going to get the final
decision and he said go for it because
we've I he knows this is how I operate
and I trust him implicitly and he knows
me for 30 years now he also knows
um the the financial markets and he
knows ah keynote he's one of the he's a
part of my will like in terms of being
executor so he knows how much money I
make and how much money I have I'm
completely open with him
and I said hey
um
what should I do about this and he said
I would do this
that's what I'm gonna do because I've
outsourced that decision so I tell you
that to tell you one of my goals is to
have a guy have a have a woman who's
brilliant at a thing have a man who's a
brilliant at a thing
um and so
when you find yourself getting anxious
about your new baby have one or two
friends someone may be a nurse
practitioner somebody may be a neonatal
nurse not everybody's got access to that
so have a doctor that you can call hey
I'm really worried about this is it okay
to let my family hold my baby because
I'm going to Outsource those decisions
that make me extra extra emotional I did
that with covid and with all the
vaccines and all the drama I knew I've
got real strong opinions and I might be
completely wrong so I'm gonna call
people that I trust in other areas of my
life and help and get their in more
informed position than mine right and I
do that with a lot of things and it just
makes a lot more peace in my life
because here's what I've come to find
out the wisest smartest smartest wisest
and most peaceful people I know say the
words I don't know but I can find out
more than anybody else I know
it's those who really struggle with
self-esteem those who really struggle
with their place in the world those who
really are trying to prove to everybody
how smart they are that always have an
opinion on everything and I I know
that's ironic because I got a show where
I'm always telling my opinion but if you
know me just hanging out I it I'll be I
don't know I don't know what do you
think I I don't know
um and I I just think that's the sign of
true wisdom so if you're struggling with
the rise of RSV and a new baby have a
medical professional who knows what
they're talking about that you trust and
ask them
then if they say yeah it's so okay for
your family to hold your baby
um then when you hang your baby over
feel that anxiousness ah my body's
trying to protect me and my baby and
then exhale
and baby's gonna be all right probably
and also know this having a baby is
scary because something could happen
you gotta always hold that that could
happen it could and trying to be a
parent that prevents everything ever
from ever happening to your kid is a
um
that's a that's a it's a miserable life
for you and that child and so we're not
gonna be We're Not Gonna not have
caution We're Not Gonna Be moronic but
also we're going to release we're going
to open our hands right call the doctor
call your friend and let's get some good
information and if it's not safe to let
your parents or family hold the baby
we're gonna say no thank you
or um baby's not We're not gonna let the
baby be held this time
cool and if they are like oh my God then
they don't get to see the baby tada
um
and I'm I'm gonna feel guilty about it
I'm gonna feel sad about it but then I'm
gonna move on with my life